let's make a start yeah so my name is
Matt Warren you probably already know
that because it's right on the screen I
should say I work for ray gun hence the
literally the ray gun on one t-shirt I
have a whole bunch of ray guns swag to
giveaway so if you like t-shirts and it
will press out wooden ray guns you can
build anything else come and chat to me
afterwards ray gun do error reporting
tools analytic tools APM tools that type
of thing so come and chat to me if
that's what you're interested in want to
find out a bit more
this talk is titled from dotnet run to
hello world had a very weird experience
this morning in Scott Hansen's keynote
where he did to the exact same demo that
I'm gonna do later on I'll keep you
guessing which one of his 35 demos or
whatever it was he did is the one I'm
gonna do but yes bizarre the experience
anyway and I should say up front I
really like I love dotnet internals for
the recording not maybe in the same way
that I love my wife and children but to
me this stuff is fascinating and maybe
that's sign it rings truth people here
this is not going to be one of those
talks where you you know make some notes
go back to work on Monday and and then
in your daily job you're gonna be
starting to hear some of the stuff I'm
talking about here and I'll just make
that clear up front I guess this is very
much a sort of informational talk there
may be times over the next year or so
there's something that in this talk
rings true to you and you think ok that
could maybe explain what's going on here
if that happens let me know I'd love to
hear the times when this talk is that
sort of thing but this is very much you
know here's what's going on under the
hood here's what happening in the.net
runtime I like digging into this stuff I
think other people do as well people
always get comments and when I write
blog posts about it people seem to want
to come to talks to listen about it as
well this is very much an informational
thing and I think that's okay I think
that's fine to learn about this stuff I
think it's good that actually is dotnet
engineers running on the.net runtime if
that's what most of us here are that we
want to have some understanding of this
runtime underneath it's generally we can
treat it as a black box you know it does
its thing we give it our code it runs it
and stuff happens but think sometimes we
run up against that and maybe another
way to think about it is actually we
should be looking to understand one
level below our usual
direction now I'm not going to argue
that every time you're coding your usual
you're one level below your usual
abstraction is beep into the in terms of
dotnet runtime we don't run into that
all the time you might be up in say you
know MVC asp.net land and that time your
abstraction is the asp.net runtime and
then we have the base class library
underneath that but who's ever used
reflector to look into some code so it's
open source now it's a bit different but
before that you'd look in some code and
you've been looking into say the base
class library and then you come up
against an internal call has every one
ever come across that so basically
that's it's saying you know we can't
give any more that at that point that
code is implemented somewhere else and
that's somewhere else is January or
always actually in these cases will be
the dotnet runtime so we have a bunch of
stuff in base class libraries written in
c-sharp and we can look at reflector use
reflector or other tools to look at that
dot peek and things like that but once
we get below that we're into the world
of c c++ and what's in the runtime and
that's what those internal calls are
they'll basically there'll be a method
with that name inside the runtime and
actually now because it's all open
source you can go onto the net net
github.com slash net slash course LR is
where the CLR open source version is
kept and you could search for that
method and you'd find that method name
in there so I think there's something in
understanding our one level below our
usual of distractions as I said I'm not
going to argue that that's day in day
out we need to do that but there's times
when we come up against it
I think another reason actually why
knowing about in terms is good is if you
want to write high performance code in
dotnet I mean Scott Hanselman in his
talk this morning talked about attacking
power benchmarks and if you go onto the
again it's all open source you go on and
look on the asp.net repository and you
can see the source code for the kestrel
web server that is the one that's being
used in those taking power benchmarks
and a guy called Ben Adams has done a
lot of performance work and some other
few from Microsoft as well and if you
follow some of that code in there it's
not the c-sharp code you would write not
by accident anyway it's highly tuned C
shot code it starts to look a little bit
more like C++ code there's like bit
shifting going on as unsafe
there's all sorts of stuff them but to
write that sort of code you need to
understand the runtime you don't write
that code backs and that's Bill of years
of knowledge it's understanding what the
GC is doing what the jitters doing how
to think how they interact what's going
on in the runtime those sorts of things
so I think that's one clear concrete
time when actually an understanding of
the runtimes is useful aside from just
you know we all like to learn this stuff
so let's start off with a bit of a demo
I'm not very good at doing live demos
I've got my notes to make sure I don't
get this wrong let's see if I can get
this right dot yes there we go that is
simultaneously the least impressive demo
you'll see all day aside from Scott
Hanson did the same one this morning but
hopefully by the end of this talk I'll
convince you that actually that's quite
impressive we do that you know maybe not
every single day but we do that quite a
lot we spin up a new console app we try
things out maybe you know now that
there's a nice neat command-line tooling
you've tried it out from the
command-line whatever we were a way we
do it we run a dotnet application maybe
many times a day when we're developing
and even just what happens between when
I type dotnet run and hello well there
there's a lot going on
aside from even if we had a proper
application that went on and did a bit
more and that's what we're going to talk
through in the next 40 minutes or so to
give an outline of where we're going
we're going to look at the main
components that make up a runtime I
think it's helpful to see what's in
there and see particularly around the
naming and stuff how the hunt the
runtime gets hosted how the runtime
initializes itself the type loader we
just write you know my class foo and
then in ignore it basically and expect
it to get on with it and do it for us
and but there's quite a lot of work that
goes into make that possible so that
types can be available at runtime they
can have type safety JIT compilation and
then everything else at the end so onto
the main components well if you're to go
into the course CLR depository this is
probably about five or six months out of
dates the numbers may have gone up or
down but anyway there's over around two
and a half million lines of source code
in there
8.2 million lines a test code there's a
lot of tests not surprisingly when
you're testing a runtime and that's just
testing the runtime there's a whole love
a lot of tests that would test the base
class libraries we're just talking about
tests that exercise something in the run
time loading types and some of the other
stuff that we'll talk about in this talk
that consider just a run time the base
class libraries in terms of
terminologies referred to as core FX and
we're talking about core CLR which is
purely the runtime there is some c-sharp
code in the runtime then we'll come on
to where that lives in the moment most
of it is in test code but there is
actually some in the runtime itself but
by far the bulk of the runtime is C and
C++ there's a lot of il again that's
testing when you want to test this sort
of stuff out they don't want to be
dependent on the compiler they want to
give it invalid il for instance to see
what the runtime does with it they want
to give it I or the structure in a
certain way so a lot of testing is
easier to done with il there's a bunch
of assembler codes not surprisingly the
runtime now runs on four or five
different CPUs arm amd64 x86 and so on
so specific parts of it have to be a
handwritten assembly and there's a bit
of Python and Perl which is as far as I
can tell build scripts there's nothing
in the actual runtime that makes out but
maybe pictures is a bit easier to
understand this is a heat map and the
size of the square is just a number of
lines of code in that particular
component and these components are the
top level folders if you to download the
code they're also terminology wise
they're the way those parts of the
runtime and referred to so if you go
onto the issues or the pull requests on
the repository and now you'll see that
they're labeled and they're often
labeled with one of these names so we'll
go through in a minute we're going to
get to the top left a huge red one
because us everything left over when
I've talked about the rest will come to
that last so we'll start with n let's
call ed this is the c-sharp code that
lives in the runtime it's as of the next
version of.net has been renamed to
system dot private or core Lib because M
s core live is sort of more from the old
older so a dotnet framework they've
renamed it with for dotnet core going
forward and but this is what sort of
code you can find in those things like
reflect
lives in there the types that we expect
system dot string system dot in those
sorts of things system but object lives
in there the basic rule of the run times
it has to be self-contained it can't
have a dependency on something else it
can't have a dependency on the base
class life it's just one of the
fundamental rules the runtime so
anything the runtime needs to do its
work has to live in the runtime but we
obviously have the nicely layered base
class library so all the stuff we kind
of generally use day in day out
system dot collections a lot of that
lives elsewhere but stuff that's tightly
integrated to the runtime is another
thing that has to live in here so system
dot string system dot array there are
fundamental types at the runtime knows
about more than anything else they're
not purely just written in c-sharp code
and there's some there's some c++ code
of mirrors and and stuff going on the
JIT knows about them instantly so it can
emit efficient code for them things like
that so that's kind of some of the rules
around what lives in the runtime as far
as possible you want to put more stuff
outside in core effects because that can
be then shared and if you're in Scott
Hanselman to talk about this idea of all
these different runtimes that sits
underneath the base class libraries core
effects that's why it makes more sense
to put things in core effects and for
instance mono is started to share more
of the core FX code other runtime so the
idea is that the runtime keeps as small
as possible but there is some rules in
that it can't have a dependency on so
anything else that's the c-sharp code
and this is the JIT just-in-time
compiler a huge chunk was a bit
surprised at quite how much code goes
into that but I suppose it makes sense
it's got a fairly complex job of turning
the il code that we give it you know we
compile our code with Rozlyn or Visual
Studio vs code how we compile our code
that ends up as il code and at runtime
that's just in time compiler if we're
talking about some of the most common
scenarios and the jitter has to do a lot
of things really and one of it has to
worry about different CPU architectures
it's got to emit different code it was
talking about emitting assemble it what
byte code basically native code for that
for the runtime so has to worry about
that it has to worry about performance
it has to worry about correctness
you know we expect our codes when we're
accessing arrays for instance we expect
the code to not go outbound
things like that has to worry about has
to worry about a missing code it's gonna
to do exception handling a lot of quite
low level stuff the JIT has to worry
about and on top of all of that in the
common scenario is just in time as in
that we can't call the method for the
first time until the code has been
cheated so it has to be fast because if
it takes too long it's not like a C C++
compiler where you can compile it once
and then that's native code it does this
at runtime and we get onto the JIT at
the end and some of the tricks used but
it's trying to do this balance between
making the most efficient kovin not
taking too long hence why there's a lot
of code in there the GC is a fun one
does anyone want to guess how big the GC
dot CPP file is it's the main file that
makes up the biggest the core of the GC
how many anyone have a guess at how many
lines of code is a thousand 22,000
that's closer 22,000 still higher anyone
anyone anyone guesses okay hot but yet
you misery if we look we can actually
look now that it's so it's so huge that
the tooling that I've got really doesn't
like it but it is thirty thirty thirty
seven thousand three hundred lines long
and you saw a sort of bit there's going
through it's a whole lot of if deaths as
well basically it's a single file that
is all the versions of the GC so it's
server GC workstation GC background GC
foreground GC multi CPU GC single CPU GC
and what it means is this file can then
be dropped into other a.net runtimes so
as far as I know it's mostly the same GC
in the.net framework and dotnet core and
they can just toggle sum if desk
basically if they want to make it have
it behave differently again for the.net
compact framework and things like that
so and and going right back fun fact the
GC was originally written in Lisp and
eased a tool to transpile it into C++
and they don't do that now but that was
how it the very first version you can
there's a blog page out there about the
guy who wrote the very
Lynnette JC I don't know if I'd like to
be a dev working on the 37,000 line code
file but I think that by this point if
you can still do it after there's one
main developers a dotnet GC developer
and she's a lady called Manny Stevens
and she's been working on the dotnet run
fine for a long time I guess is she
isn't fed up with working like this and
it's going to stay like this people have
opened an issue you can search for it on
the github repository of why is this one
single file could it be a Fae refactored
and you can you can search for that and
read up why but that's the bulk of that
GC GC like the Jetta sort of relatively
stand-alone they have an interface they
talk to the rest the runtime but now you
can operate on their own thing the
runtime calls into them and then and
they call back into the bulk of the rest
of the runtime which is the red block
for an interface but they can stand
alone and in fact there's actually a
sample in the repository where you can
use that GC outside of the dotnet
runtime there's a fairly simple sample
showing actually here's the GC can be
used that way and is also the reverse of
that has work being done where you can
provide an alternative GC to the dotnet
runtime if you really want to do that as
an interface you have to implement and
then you can do the work and there's a
guy called Conrad's I forget her name
but he's just written a dotnet GC book
called net memory management it's a
thousand pages long which shows you how
much is in the GC but on his blog he's
talked about the alternative G seeing
what's done this that's worth looking up
if G sees more of your thing
garbage collection these two blocks here
are purely to do with debugging it's
what the runtime provides so that where
you can debunk so SOS who's heard of SOS
Sun and strike a few of you must so if
you're debugging net in windbg
you must know the magic commands dot
load by SOS CLR that's the SOS here and
what it is providing is a view of the
your.net process when DB g is only knows
about native you know not managed code
is basically an SOS provides commands
like give me a list of all the dotnet
threads runtimes rates give me a list of
the school stack give me the method of
this location
give me the ILO of the method
the assembly code of the method those
sorts of things that's what it provides
and it has to map between those two
worlds so there's quite a lot going on
there and the other part of that is the
the per point at the top DAC is the main
is called a data access component and
that's purely providing if you imagine
you have your dotnet process as a chunk
of memory the DAC is like a view on top
of that and it allows it to cool it and
so that that chunk of memory is a large
amount of its data structures at the
runtime keeps so there's a data
structure in the runtime which is the
list of all the threads as a data
structure in a runtime for every class
that you load for every method and the
DAC is a way to say give me those
information about those data structures
from this process either a memory dump
or a live process so we pretty much take
it for granted we hit f5 and we're f10
stepping through or whatever it is and
and obviously if we're doing that
individual studio or vs codes that end
of it is providing a lot of that
functionality but quite a lot of
functionality is also provided by the
runtime to make it debug a debugger or
book is that even a word to make it easy
for us to debug it to make it easy for
us to inspect those processes and
without this sort of stuff we wouldn't
get very far
debugging our code which is handy the
PAL is just a small thing on the side
the idea of this is you might have heard
of this from save windows and things
like the platform abstraction layer and
the idea is this is the part of the
runtime that is dealing with different
os's
so now that we have dotnet core running
on Linux UNIX different flavors mac OS
and obviously windows as well that the
idea is that the abstraction of those
bits is in one place and the rest of the
runtime can just cool methods that might
call out to the OS and this this part
handles that and an Inc in the middle is
really a whole bunch of header files and
interfaces of the different how the
different components so for instance
there's one in there which is the GC -
AE which is the top left execution
engine and there's an interface of those
to talk to each other and vice versa Lin
the EE talks back to the GC the same for
the AE and the Jets and the JIT and
backwards but also some of these are
external ones so
anyone here work on sort of third-party
tools using internet debugging API is
profiling api's anyone okay well you
you're using native tools if you're not
working on them any third-party debugger
and you to like Rider that provides a
debugging experience in there any
third-party tools like the one I work
for Raygun but other tools that provides
a p.m. or Diagnostics experience we're
probably be using some of these API
there's a whole range of API is the
runtime provides the people who want to
write unfortunately almost all those
api's are you have to access them from C
and C++ they're not API is for for
managed code but they do mean we can
have an ecosystem of tooling around this
and there's a stable and API provided
there and he told tool writers can
provide rely on that and the VM then is
basically everything else and it's got
bits per CPU assembly code in there
but what's actually contained in there
well there's a whole lot of things the
type system and we just as I said we
just write class some class and code and
but the runtime needs to know that it
reads in as it loads our dll's
it will read it into his own data
structure and it has to do that for a
few reasons one is because it needs to
work within itself but another one is
because of reflection when you use
reflection it has to have that
information available so that it can say
right yes that type you're asking me to
before has this fields or has these
properties has these methods and that
started some of the data structures it
keeps in there and generics as well a
were for special mention we kind of
again we probably like quite like using
generics but as a whole lot of work went
in the whole run time to make generics
possible because generics and net was
done in a way where it was done I guess
in in a peer or Java took a different
route we say with generics and we have
generics baked into the runtime real
generics if you like and there's a lot
of work that was done to make that
possible all the built-in types are in
the in the VM as well loading of types
and classes threading the abstraction of
threading and I'm not even talking about
the level of the thread pool and stuff
of that which lives actually outside of
the runtime but just the raw net threads
are an instruction on top of OS threads
exception handling a stack walking we
probably take these for granted or don't
like them because any time we see an
exception maybe we're tasked with
figuring out why it's happening in our
in our code but we probably wouldn't
want to do that if we didn't have a nice
stack trace and and and we could
probably be quite grateful the runtime
provides that if you've ever done any
work in C or C++ or other runtimes that
don't give you that nice stack reporting
but again a lot of work has to take
place to make that happen it's not
straightforward event tracing and
profiling anyone used heard of etw event
tracing for Windows a few people and
anyone else heard of a tool called per
few few more people that Coquina gets
out in a moment anyway there's some
tools that will let you collect events
at the runtime itself emits and and in
in atw events are obviously across all
over the Windows OS but the ones that
the dotnet runtime omits of things like
GC events happening allocations
happening chitting so sort of the
runtimes telling you something's
happening in the runtime and you can use
perfume or you can actually write code
with libraries from new get that let you
capture those events and you can have a
nice them to see what's going on
an MP invoke dotnet has quite a nice
story of calling out to native code if
anyone had ever put you know DLL import
attribute that sort of stuff is quite a
lot of work to make that happen it has
to make sure that the data from dotnet
gets put into the right format that the
native code expects and then when that
comes back and vice versa has to make
sure that any exceptions that happen
native Qaeda turned into dotnet
exceptions and and things like that
there's quite a lot of work going on
that just in p.m. VOC so that's the
virtual machine so when I ran that demo
before I types dotnet run and there's
various other ways you can do next
exe C execute but all of those
ultimately end up calling into something
called the hosting API and that's
because our net code is not native code
so something has to initialize the
runtime and the runtime has to run our
code unless we're talking about ahead of
time compilation in net so you have that
in a mano a bit and
design called core RT in in.net core
world side of things unless we're
talking about it's ahead of time
compilation our code that we give the
runtime is not native code so it has to
something has to start at the runtime if
you've anyone played around with the new
tuning where you can do dotnet publish
and those sorts of things people
familiar with that so that's a way to
get more self-contained apps you know
you the folder with the entire runtime
and if you notice in there when you
publish your application you'll have
your my app DLL and you'll have my app
dot exe my app DXE is basically a
wrapper that is that contain calls into
the hosting API initializes a runtime
and says I'd like you to run my app DLL
find its main entry point or whatever it
might be and as a few steps it goes
through this is one of the API is that
lives in that diagram I talked about
before and I'm not going to go through
it all because you can there's a quite a
nice MS MSDN Docs but maybe the
interesting bit is actually that app
domains are still a thing Internet core
so one of the things that went away with
dotnet cool is the ability to create app
domains we can no longer use app domains
as an IDE as a as a process of isolation
and they've sort of said that's not a
real thing you know in terms of that's
not real isolation that's not really fit
for purpose if you want isolation run
multiple processes that domains and no
longer the way to have that but there's
still one app domain living in the
runtime and the hosting API maybe that
will go away eventually but it's tied in
to this API so probably will break too
much stuff it now lives on a sort of
historical thing you can't as I think
there's almost no method you can call an
active system that domain left anyway
you certainly can't spin up new nap
domains there is a new mechanism called
application contexts if you want some of
the isolation app domains give you in
terms of loading plugins and things like
that
and but in terms in dotnet core app
domains don't live except behind the
scenes but it goes through these steps
but let's see action so this is the code
from that web page I'm not going to talk
you through all because you probably
didn't come here to see C++ code
it talks through the steps but let's see
in action so we're just going to run up
the host and ask it to execute a dll and
the benefit of obviously this all been
open sources you can put your own crazy
ascii text in and pretend that you made
your own version the see a lot but the
point is it's running through a load of
things it's setting up the application
pass you can sort of see net core app
it's initializing it this is roughly
what happens when you type dotnet run
the same sort of steps it goes through
really what it's doing is collecting up
all the Assemblies that are considered
part of the runtime you know so all the
dll's system dot all the ones that live
in the base class library in the.net
core world most those come by NuGet
packages and if you store Scott
Hanselman talked this morning they live
under that fold away you can have
different versions subside by side so
this is this hosting API here is is the
simple one it's really look here's a
fold with a load of deals and here's my
main dealer I'd like to run do it in the
world of dotnet run it's doing a lot
more behind the scenes it's deciding
which one tiny want to use it knows
about dotnet standard on that core app
but the bulk of it the bottom of it all
is really here's some deals that you're
gonna need here's the main DLL go and
run the runtime and then the end of it
we get nice hello world as before
so we've seen how the runtime gets
initialized the next thing it does sorry
we've seen how the runtime gets hosted
the next thing it does is it has to
initialize itself there's a whole lot of
stuff that goes on if you've ever heard
people say dotnet looks bad in sort of
small hello world benchmarks is because
the runtime is doing quite a lot of
initialization with the expectation that
you're going to do more than print hello
world it's getting stuff ready for your
app your application to run for a bit
longer than that so if you do it you
know if you tie in the time it takes for
dotnet app to start up print hello world
and exit it's gonna look bad compared to
a C++ app that's because there's a whole
lot of stuff that's gone on there and
you've just kind of wasted all that
you've asked a runtime to start up and
then you've gone away and done nothing
useful with it but some of the things it
does so it needs to set itself up it has
a whole lot of low-level components and
if you're really keen because I counted
it you can read the 68 things to see how
it does before executing a line of your
code and we'll look at that but in
effect there's one method in the runtime
initializes all the sub components and a
lot of the stuff we saw in that diagram
earlier initializes things it starts up
things like error handling obviously the
runtime has its own error handling if
the right time goes wrong is anyone ever
seen fatal engine it fatal
engine execution exception I think that
you're doing well if you get a sense I
think that's basically the runtime
saying I don't know something's gone
horribly wrong so the fact you don't see
that very often means at the runtime you
know it has its own except error
handling exception handling built-in and
it does a better job so you get things
like stack overflow exceptions or out of
memory exceptions those sorts of things
but they're being converted from
something happening in native code by
the time we see them they're coming up
as many as exceptions even though you
might not be profiling on debugging it
needs to get ready for the dip for
instance a debugger to attach at a later
time so there's things being spun up
there
GC needs to get ready so that by the
time your codes darhk's executing you
can start allocating and so it needs to
initialize itself domains if applicable
yeah there's a whole load of things just
to show it in codes to see this is the
this is the problem this is the function
that runs through and you can just see
initializing initializing initializing
legit initializing the the power liar
initializing a debugger initializing
exists and handling and so on and so on
setting up threading stubs we'll come to
at the end what that's going on there
but and there's a something that you see
the runs are news is quite widely
garbage collecting anyway the point is
there's a lots going on that's the point
on it make more than exactly that all
the specifics but if you really want to
look up the EE helper function that runs
it up you can again because it's a local
source you can go and take a look at the
end of all that the run times is
initializes itself it's then ready to go
send ready to start executing our code
but let's look at that in a slightly
different way so a few of you said
you've heard of perfu before that's good
I kind of make it my aim to tell more
people about perfu but if he has a
slightly bad rap as you'll see in a
minute is when you load up per few it
looks like this and there's no plot me
trying to even zoom in really because
it's not gonna you know it's it's an
interesting UI wise but I always argue
perfu that I would rather have a very
powerful tool that looked horrendous
then a very pretty tool that did nothing
useful and perf use very much at that
end of the scale there's a lot of
powerful low-level information get out
of perf you it does take a little bit of
digging around it does take a little bit
of getting used to it has got a bit
better since it's open source as well so
people have been community contributions
and sending that as far as I know a lot
of the Microsoft teams themselves use
perfume for diagnosing performance
issues particularly you can certainly go
on the repositories and see people
posting screenshots from perfu
and there's a few things it will give
you we're going to look at and CPU
sampling in a moment to see what the
runtime does drew and startup you can
use that for your own code so it's a
it's a sampling profiler where it takes
a snapshot of the call stack once every
mini second and at the end of that you
can see where the most time is spent it
will also tell you about memory Alec
patience and that can be native ones as
in what the doclet runtimes doing but
more important more importantly for us I
guess is we can see dotnet allocations
or our codes allocator
a lot of this is also available in
third-party tools I should say so a lot
of the third-party profiling tools can
get your similar information perfuse
just another way of getting it
it also hooks into etw events but let's
and I'm going to show you the if you
thought that first screen was interested
in this one no nice responsive UI
hearing it's but we're just going to run
a the main one is we're gonna run with
CPU samples turned on and if anyone
knows what all of these tick boxes do
please come and tell me afterwards
because every time I look at it I get
more confusing as new ones pop up
there's three that have the word dotnet
and Alec I look for allocation Xin and I
always get confused which ones which
anyway
you basically give it an application and
you give it a command line and you and
you run a command and then it does some
very weird things with Windows and it's
has a nice you can tell it's low level
because this is the this is the progress
report you get this is the yeah anyway
it's going to go away and do its thing
it's collecting etw events coming out of
the dotnet runtime that's what it's
doing there perfu so that those roar
events are relatively easy to collect
what perfume top of that is builds a
whole lot of intelligence so it collects
for instance if we're talking about GC
allocations it'll collect the raw events
but it'll analyze those and say actually
these represent GC pauses at GC pauses
are significant because in a lot of
situations when as a GC pause that's the
GC running and not your code running and
that can be a performance issue so it
does some work there so it's yeah it's
done all that so we then get a nice data
file
[Music]
yes yes yes and this is the first screen
I think if you've got if you've done
perfu if you tried out / if you got to
this screen and you see this and this
sort of stuff at this point you probably
give up is a bit cryptic but what it's
really telling you is how long is spent
in each method exclusively as in just
that method in and inclusively including
as children but fortunately they've
recently or an open-source contribution
built signed called flame graphs and
unfortunately they don't really you know
they don't really demo nicely so I'll
show you in a different way in a second
but flame graphs as an aside has anyone
heard of flame graphs before I just
mentioned them I get a few people but a
few can either learn roughly what flame
works give you flame grass give you is a
way of analyzing or in this case we're
talking about CPU samples so it's where
time was spent the main thing to
remember is it's not over time this is
is taking all the samples so we I think
I ran that program there for 10 seconds
it collects its CPU samples once every
millisecond at the end of it puts them
all together so what's on the left as
the flame graph isn't what happened
first and then right the left-to-right
order is almost arbitrary but what it is
is the wider the block the more time is
spent in that function so an obviously
in a lot of call stacks there's common
functions you know so at the bottom we
generally have main if things starts in
Mayton right 100% the time is spent it
may be but that's not very useful
because nothing useful was done in main
it was the functions it's called what
you're looking generally for flame grass
is a flat is a function that's flat
because it doesn't have any children
that means actually 20% of our time has
just spent in in this case the byte
function right teeth is a lot of time
but most of the time is not in teeth
itself it's in it's children so that's
the thing to look out for alligator and
pans are useful because they're to kind
of make the two main functions but not
very much time as spending them
individually is stuff after them as a
very quick aside if you haven't checked
out or not heard of Julia Evans and her
blog is JV and SCA
or she's known as a pork on Twitter she
makes these fantastic zine designs
explaining quite complex technical
things in this sort of way there's loads
of them
this is one she's done on flame graphs
there's other ones on processes on low
level stuff but explained in a really
engaging way so hopefully that's given
you an idea if you haven't before on
what flame graphs do and what they look
like let's have a look saying in sort of
Blue Peter style here's one I prepared
earlier because unless I clean it up and
make it on a slide it's impossible to
see what's going on in perfu but the
point is we're seeing larger sections
but even still I know you're not gonna
be able to see that so anyway this is
what it looks like if it's annotated and
this is where the runtime spent its time
in that HelloWorld application until it
called our code so you see a whole chunk
of the time is actually cheating and
running the actual code itself because
when you first call the main method that
then has to call it has to then at some
point has to then get the console dot
write line method for instance and
sometimes those methods call behind the
scenes that we don't explicitly call in
our code so there's a bit of time spent
in getting their system domain set up is
roughly the managed code set up and then
e startup is the 68 steps I talked to
you in the previous slide that's what's
going on there that's thing starting up
there and so yeah that's what in times
of typed in times of in terms of time
Spencer e that's where it is then and
that's why I think in this one one of
these thin bars here is actually
executing the program don't might not
forget what it is but anyway this is why
we say like hallow welds benchmarks you
know very little this time is spent in a
executing our code all right as all the
other stuff that goes around it
obviously you only pay that JIT in cost
once but if you're just printing hello
world to the screen next thing you're
doing all that work to not get it reused
as I said before it's not like left to
right so this actually happens first and
then this and then this one finally but
it ranges it differently it's over this
is the whole sample so that gives you an
idea of what it looks like in x Ben
fun thing with this so I am I used this
before I tweeted this out and happens
that one of the runtime engineers
follows me on Twitter and realized from
the screenshot and another one I a
larger one I tweeted that actually
there's some stuff happening in in a
kind of hello world application that
shouldn't be happening because in terms
of the runtime they're quite they take
quite a good-looker actually what the
runtime does before arc I can execute in
this kind of world of micro services and
when we're spinning up things a lot more
the time to our code being executed is
important right you know the times that
often it means the time to first request
right we've seen no snow is where the
first request takes a long time they do
what they can in the runtime to make
sure the runtime gets out the way only
initialize is what it has to and I can't
take much credit I stumbled across his
backs not even know I was seeing a
problem but I I tweeted it more out of
interest but they saw it and basically
said they were doing stuff in that
process that shouldn't have been done
they were doing stuff that shouldn't
didn't need to be done before the users
code was executed that could have been
done afterwards like asynchronously in
the background type thing and so as of
dotnet 3 they fixed that and it's around
saying called event pipe controllers and
it's a diagnostic thing but the point of
that is to actually they do look at this
or stuff is important to them how many
methods are ejected before your code is
how many methods are automatically
jutted even if you don't call those
sorts of things how many things the
runtime does they tried to make sure it
does the bear mainly because they
realize and particularly going forward
with containment as in docker and all
this sort of stuff this thing is more of
an issue the other main thing the
runtime does is allocate a bunch of
memory and that's pretty much all the
bulk of it sorry is for the GC so the
runtime itself allocates a whole load of
memory that he uses but that's kind of a
bit hidden from us and we can't really
do much about that the runtime does that
the bit that we can control is is what
the GCS do because if we're allocating
lots of memory in our code or lots of
objects that need lots of memory in our
code then the GC has to do a bit more
work but the GC 3 allocates a bunch of
memory upfront so it's got the heaps
ready to go so that when you want an
allocation you
as the memory already pre-allocated that
varies across workstation server 32-bit
64-bit it's also quite smart with
reserving memory verse is actually
paging it in and that sort of thing it
works you know in a smart way with the
OS so you won't nestle see these in the
kind of headline figure if you look in
in task manager whatever but it's it's
doing that but it's very is it's getting
to the state where the first time you
knew up an object or allocate some
memory it's got a chunk of memory that
it can give you you know a section of
that memory ready to go and then in late
2006 work of cleaning up that memory and
it tries to relieve memory intelligently
as well so we've seen that the runtime
being initialized externally we've seen
the runtime initializing itself
internally if you like we've seen where
it spends its time doing that some of
the main components and now it's the
type later we just write you know as a
set of few times we just write our types
but there's a kind of fundamental thing
that we expect is that type safety isn't
there's certain rules you know that if
you write code like this you're going to
get a compiler error because you're
trying to new up an abstract class right
the same if you try to new up an
interface away though if you try to use
it access a private field of a method we
set reflection is different if you're
using that that's a different mechanism
but certainly in regular code if you try
to access private fields there's certain
rules you can't have multiple
inheritance all these sorts of things
the type system provides us dotnet is a
strongly typed language the runtime and
has to care about as well because what
the runtime can't do is just rely on all
our code coming from a nice compiler so
that so you use Visual Studio vs code
way of it it won't let you write code
like this or it won't sorry it refused
to compile code like this it'll give you
an error and it won't compile it there's
nothing to stop you if you saw again
actually if Scott Hanson was talk this
morning it's nothing to stop you using
the il dasn't all to disassemble from a
dll into il you can edit that and then
you can use il azzam to assemble it back
and it does virtually no type system
checks it will check on the syntax of
the il that's about it and actually that
there's a reason because they want that
tool to be able to write invalid
i L so that I can test it in the runtime
if there's no way to create these sorts
of scenarios they can test it the main
point is is the runtime has to do its
own checks it can't just assume all this
code has come from a nice compiler
there's various different ways you can
you know you can edit the binary itself
if you get that far but the point is it
has to do these checks itself at runtime
so when it's doing the type loads it
needs to check for these things are you
trying to access a class you shouldn't
are you breaking class hierarchies
whatever it might be the runtime has to
pretty much mirror all the checks that
the compiler would do but it doesn't in
terms of throwing a type load exception
doesn't give you a nice error message
saying the line of codes are fixed it
just says type load exception you can't
do this or whatever it might be but it
gets a bit more complicated does anyone
want to admit they've ever written code
like this the main point is and I after
having looked about it quite a lot of
times I'm not a compiler or a language
person the main point is is class a is
dependent on Class B and Class B is
dependent on Class A you've got a
recursive mutual whatever the right word
is but it's at the type level it's not a
runtime determine you know it's so the
point to remember is Class B shouldn't
load if Class A is broken and Class
acient load is Class B is broken but
which one you do first you names like
chico neck so either they have to both
be okay and they both have to load or if
one of them's broken they can't neither
of them can load because at that point
the types they make sense
you break type safety all this sort
stuff and it mostly comes in with
generics it's hard to do this sort of
crazy recursive stuff at a type layer
without genetics but yeah if anyone can
come talk to me afterwards and say what
you could replace a B and C with real
names to make this a real life proper
scenario I'd love to hear of where you
could actually justify writing code like
this but anyway it's possible to write
it so what the type what the type system
does when it's loading is it loads
everything in stages it starts with the
class just loaded as raw data and then
it works through and you can see things
like it's looking at the parents of the
class exact parents and its dependencies
and it basically goes through so in
those cases we have two class
depend and it'll move through all the
types to each level so it'll get all
types to level one and all types to
level to all types of level three and
then it knows you know for instance it
knows that this type can't move to load
its dependencies because one of its
dependencies is broken so this type you
know type a couldn't progress past this
stage because type B hasn't gotten to
this data eyesore think so every type
has two dependent types have to move up
in at the same level and then once you
get to the end when all the dependencies
are loaded you know that dependents are
loaded so you know that you're okay
because your dependencies are all okay
they wouldn't have got to that stage if
they weren't themselves okay and so on
and it's a bit like the way transactions
are committed in a database you know
everything sort of moves up in steps and
at the end it says right is everyone
happy and it does the final step at the
end which is basically flipping a bit
saying right we've got this far there's
been no errors okay everything's good we
can say the types are okay it's a very
simplified version of what it's doing
but it works through these stages so we
finally finally got to the point our
code will actually run that's the thing
all of this is before any of our codes
run if we leave aside static
initializers which are slightly
different beside a thing but in our
hello world example all this would have
happened before anything in our code
would have run and we have JIT
compilation as I've talked about before
in dotnet and it works a bit like this
the point of what is trying to do is
that it doesn't want a jitter method
until you actually call it right so it
could as as every single type was load
at the beginning it could say right this
types got five methods on legit and you
know one two three four five and but
that would waste a lot of time if you
never called those methods all those
methods didn't call get cool too later
so what the runtime does is when it
emits a method it actually emits it has
a temporary energy point but it goes
through a series of stops and stubs the
simplest way to think about those is
like a few instructions of assembly and
not a full method cool and they just do
a bit of housekeeping so the first time
when you tried to call a method it comes
through this route it starts off at the
temporary entry point because that's
that's where it knows the method is and
it gets the pre-code fix up the free
stuff and the priests of work
is basically the bit that calls the JIT
so the first time it calls a method it
gets pushed through these series of
stops and it ends up having the method
JIT it afterwards
when it's been cheated he's done a few
extra things so we've lost the pre stub
now it's lost that level of doing
direction that's gone off and what it's
done is it's rewritten in effect this
fix up to now point directly to the
native code viola stubborn when I say
rewritten we're talking about assembly
instructions being changed and address
in effect and that free code fix that
will be you saying like use this address
and jump to it and it's done is between
the first and second time that address
will change for the first time it jumps
to the pre-start the second time it
jumps the native code it's also built
this stable entry point and that is so
that that point onwards to rest the
runtime knows that anytime you want to
call this method go to the stable entry
point it'll always end at the right
place the temperature point can be
changed this is the simple sort scenario
it gets more complex when you have
things like virtual method dispatch
because it has to decide which way to go
which implementation of the method when
you include interfaces so the simplest
scenario is an instance method on a
class or a static method anything above
that gets more complicated generics you
know we know in generics things are done
differently if you have a generic you
have a generic method that takes T wait
T is an INT or a double that's shared
code whereas sorry that's individual
code for those there's a different
method implementation for the intrusion
than a double version whereas if it
takes T words here's at the reference
type is shared codes and some tricks
going on there and it's using these
stubs in different places we just call
the method but the runtime figures this
out for us but something fundamentally
changed around the dotnet call 2.0 time
frame and there's a new feature came in
as an unheard of it it's around JIT
compilation it's also written on the
bottom the screen I just list so it's on
C a compilation year so T compilation
came in around net
core 2.1 and it's not sort of a dotnet
standard thing so i don't know how
when other runtimes might implemented
but it's in net core it was turned off
by default into that one I believe as of
net core 3 it'll be on by default and
that does something different so the the
main issue is all of this is and you can
kind of see in action here is that the
first time I methods called it has to
the JIT has to do its job right and and
it's had this trade-off maybe if it
could spend a long time it could
generate super efficient code so that if
that method then gets called thousands
of times a second it's you know two
percent faster which obviously a
thousands of times a second makes a
difference right but if it spends too
long it's blocking that method being
called the first time and maybe that
methods only called once and it's on the
start off of your app and it's between
the user being able to first push a
button the wave raise the G it doesn't
know that right so it has to kind of
take a middle ground it has to say wrong
and do the best I can but I don't want
to do anything that takes too long I
can't do some of the optimizations that
a C C++ compiler that works if you like
offline and can do so it's always been a
bit limited by that so what JIT
compilation sorry what tiered
compilation is is and it's something
that's been around in Java and JVM under
the hot spot compiler for quite a while
but it's coming new to net is that it
will actually have a way that it can JIT
the method more than once so up to now
in dotnet framework the methods been
cheated once and that's it that's then
the native code that's run every single
time from that point onwards take
compilation kind of breaks that
dependency and says tell you what the
first time and methods called will do
the most basic thing will just get some
code out those because the possibility
be correct it will be you know is not
we're not going to check anything out
there but it will be the minimum they
call it min ops minimize minimum
optimization and that doesn't do any of
the clever tricks but it means it can do
it very quickly so it helps startup time
because it can JIT these methods quicker
then if that method is called lots of
times let's have another go at it and
let's do the max from optimizations or
what we would have done before or even
more you know once it's got the two
modes it can then decide and that's done
in an asynchronous way so once the
methods being called enough times ok
right this methods important it's on the
hot path whatever it's called enough
times
I'm gonna in the background this method
again I'm gonna do the full
optimizations I can take not as long as
I want but you know taking seconds when
it's in the background asynchronously is
not an issue and it's worthwhile because
if that method then goes on to be called
a lot more time just the extra work the
JIT can do there so in terms of the main
differences there's another level of
indirection after it's been fitted and
it goes through the priest of again if
you see with two compilation and that
free stub at the moment is basically a
fairly simple counter and it counts how
many times then the native code is
actually called and then when it gets to
a certain point it says right okay this
is a method I consider to be important
I'm going to ask the jitter on a
background thread to do this and then
when it's finished it has the switches
in again levels of indirection it can
just point so now points to the
optimized native code he still got the
original native code because there's
various reasons you might want to swap
back to that or it needs to have that
for debugging and certain things like
that so it still has that native
original code around it did the first
time and once this is in there and they
tell you on debug by default and they
see that the main issue why they didn't
turn it on by default in the first place
is because this is an extra level of
indirection you're paying a little bit
of a cost to go through this mechanism
even if you don't use it so they're
making sure they can make that as quick
as possible or within you know
acceptable limits because once you have
this mechanism in then there can be lots
of reasons you might want to optimize
code if anyone knows like say jvn and
the hotspot compiler one of the issues
you get with virtual methods is if
there's only one concrete implementation
or sort of interface implementations
there's only one class the influencer
interface you don't need to do the
runtime lookup to say right it's Class A
or Class B you can just say right
there's only one concrete instantiation
but the problem with that is if a type
gets loaded later a second class that
also implements that interface it has to
turn that optimization off and Nets not
being able to do that he's always had to
allow for that second scenario so this T
compilation gives more benefits down the
line and I think we're going to see once
it's turned on and they know that the
you know
killing performance and but helping
performance then they're going to start
to use it in more things and it means
that the main promise is that the JIT
compiler the second time around can do
lots more things it can be a lot more
intelligent it could potentially look at
collecting other information along the
way things like that so that's one of
the few bits of this tool that is stuff
around in dotnet course everything else
so we've we've talked about JIT
compilation at this point our main
method has been executed but that's not
quite everything else because we have
these stubs because when we call out to
console dot write line that's not
implemented in you know that's calling
out to the OS or the C++ library or
wherever it is it's something outside of
the dotnet runtime that does to use that
and sort of talked about at the
beginning but this is so to be clear all
this is this is all the methods that
were just in that application this is
saying you can pull out from perfu I'm
not entirely sure what he's span helpers
are here actually I need to figure that
one out but we can see our hello world's
main there and then these stubs the way
it works with peer invoke you can see
they end up in system console that's
because we're calling cansado right line
and these are basically overload you've
got an int you've got one with now in
you've got into 32 sorry in int when it
starts to call out to native methods
when you have in effect the DLL import
attributes behind the scenes this is
what it's doing it's creating these
stubs so that when you call that method
again level of indirection
yeah actually goes via stub the stub
does whatever housekeeping needs to be
done before actually calling into the
native method and that is mostly if we
take the example of console dat right
line that'll be converting the string
from a dotnet managed string into
whatever format the native library and
also making sure that the garbage
collector doesn't move that string
around while it's in that method because
the garbage collector expects to be able
to move objects around as and when it
wants but once control passes out it's a
native code that you know it's different
so it has to do some things around
safety there and then when that method
returns it checks the error code from
the native method if your if the native
method is returning data back into the
runtime it needs to turn that Marshall
that back from there's a few things
there so that's what's going on there
so he finally after 15 minutes walk
through everything that the runtime does
in that simple application just want a
few caveats so we never triggered the GC
in that simple application there's a few
things that would happen if your
application was a lot longer running and
a few bits the runtime but you know 50
minutes is enough for anyone to have any
stuff but if you want more information I
blog about this sort of stuff
lots of other people do so that's the
resources for learning net internals as
a post I've done there that's other
people's blogs on this tools if you're
an explorer this yourself or techniques
that I use when I'm exploring it if
people are interested in that level
other presentations and talks there's
quite a lot of people who are talking
about Dada internals in different ways
the book at the runtime is a books a bit
anyway it's markdown documents is text
and but what it is is written by the
dotnet runtime engineers for other
dotnet runtime engineers so it's not an
introductory text we say but what it is
is a real good explanation of why this
stuff does what is and how it works a
lot of my blog posts are basically I
read the page on there about some topics
that walking exception handling I figure
I know maybe 10% of it I then go away
did a bit more research look at the code
come back and then by the time I think I
can read that page and it makes sense to
me I figure I'll probably learn enough
to write blog post so I try and write
posts that might help people get into
the runtime look at the runtime book but
yeah if you're into runtimes anyway you
might find it easy to get into but it's
not meant as an introductory so that is
it any questions yes
yeah so the question is about tools for
the lowly looking at low level stuff
cross-platform I mostly do this on
Windows so I don't know for sure but
what I have seen is that clearly in the
beginning you know when they were
getting when I porting to other run
times they're basically making the apps
work and it's only over time that
tooling has grown so recently so that's
that perfu at 5 jg clean that's not
gonna be cross-platform it's like WPF
the UI but the collection part of the
per few apps is more across platforms as
a per script will let you at least click
those events on non Windows OS and then
on a Windows OS you can analyze them I
think they're trying to make more
tooling that doesn't require that
because even that level is maybe not
great and but as far as I know the
profiling and debugging api's are
cross-platform ok so that's why you
started to see tools but yeah clearly
we've had a hit heritage of being
Windows only so stuff doesn't catch up
but perfuse probably the one that's they
try and as they add new features like
Ted compilation is now per few events so
they try and make sure that perfu is the
one place you can get your stuff I think
because they use it themselves whether
there's going to be a cross-platform per
field I know but at least at the moment
you can collect it on other systems so
that's probably your best option for
that stuff per few aside from yeah like
we're pretty spoiled with so you can
debug through I showed you the code and
video you can debug through the runtime
of Visual Studio if you want to do the
same you have to use gdb and stuff it
out so I think you can use I think the
best option you have for debugging on
other platforms is they made Gd but they
made SOS work on gdb so you've got you
couldn't have windbg debugging you can
do that level on in terms of the runtime
for dotnet code is slightly different so
it's not it's not it's not up there as
Windows yeah yeah when is we've had yeah
ten years of just being Windows only so
that they are I know that they realize
it's something that's missing and I know
what I've seen recently is amazing a lot
more of the global to link so you can
have things like you know you've got
run they're going to have dotnet and
dump for making a memory dump net source
for symbols collecting the symbols
dotnet analyze a sort so there's a yes I
think he's under dotnet slash
Diagnostics as a repository into the
command line to cover the other way
they're going forward as well yeah I
have any other questions yes yeah yeah
so you're right yeah we saw in that when
I showed that demo so and I believe that
sort of the assemblies that the yeah
I've not looked into how it treats a
differently base is things like the
Assemblies that I think a mandatory have
to be there and I think they have
special rules and that they can do stuff
that more higher-level assemblies can
but generally I think they equate
roughly they equate to what's the name
of in the.net you know you have the
dotnet core app you know you don't you
don't include them all in the beginning
of dotnet core you had to include
everything you know you had to include
system dot string as a DLL they bundle
those up into the kind of meta packages
and I think that trusted platform
assemblies roughly equate to those meta
passages which is like everything that's
kind of mandatory and I don't know how
it works in terms of security because we
no longer have code access security and
things like that I don't think it really
affects that you know they can do that
sort of thing
okay yeah yes yeah yeah yes so I think
they would get added to the trusted
platform assemblies list yeah I think
possibly it might be the distinction
might be anything that's come from the
runtime all of the base class libraries
counters trusted platform versus user
code as in you know what code we'd write
ourselves I think that might be the
distinction between trusted platform
assemblies and elsewhere but all that
stuff is is outside of the runtime so
that simple launcher app you know Matt
CLR thing I showed you that doesn't have
any knowledge of that that's still built
into the dotnet tooling you know dotnet
run and stuff with that that handles
that at the end of the day I think
basically all that does is build up the
trusted platforms assemblies lists and
passes it to the hosting API and says
right here so but it does it goes
through different routes doesn't it it
picks up that JSON it you know pulls
down NuGet packages it knows about
dependencies it knows about storing all
that sauce stuff it knows where to look
for the different runtimes but yeah the
runtime really doesn't know anything
about that the main way stuff is passed
into the runtime is that track trusted
platform assemblies list and then
basically environment variables settings
and yeah you know GC configuration
settings as there's very that the core
of the hosting API is pretty simple it's
like here Cindy allows is the
fundamental modes like GC workstation or
server and then off it off you guys yeah
any other questions
yes
yeah yeah yes yes yes so the question
was around now that domains have gone
one of the things that people would have
done with them is using it there's a way
to load plugins and then at the end of
it tear down the app to main than that
go away or things like that so they have
something called is it application
context sorry
assembly like I said thank you thank you
yeah that's em below context and it's
under the banner of unload ability and
the recent preview sorry the recent post
about dotnet core 3 preview 2 has a
section on unload ability and if you
scroll down there there's a design doc
and how to dock and for that scenario
yes is exactly what it's meant for it's
meant for
I'd like to load some dll's in I
promised not to have any dependencies on
those in code that's still there cuz
that's one of the issues is once you
have a you know a link across it can't
tear down that if it knows you're
storing in a static field or whatever it
is but as long as you respect that at
the end of it or actually not the end of
it the garbage collector when it knows
that it will then clean up so yeah that
unload ability and so they're sort I
think they're doing stuff in that kind
of way more explicit right this is one
scenario this is actually what people
were using app domains for a lot of the
times the the proper isolation is not a
thing it's the actual the fact you want
to load some stuff at the end of it you
want to take it away
so they've gone down that route yeah
oh yeah
yeah yeah I don't you because Java has a
class like this doesn't and it can be
yeah I don't think it's quite as
configurable as that but it's yeah I
think starting to get that way where you
can certainly you can load sorry yeah I
don't think it's going to go dear cousin
from my own son in Java you have
different class loaders and and stuff
that's loaded in one class later can't
see things in another I don't think
they're with you haven't looked into the
unload ability stuff loads to know but I
don't think it sort of prevents you
calling across outside of it it's it's
more of when I'm done with these things
I want them to go away because of memory
and I don't want them hanging around
especially if they're dll's on disk you
don't want to reference it that sort of
stuff so any more questions no okay
thank you very much please come and get
t-shirts and stickers because I don't
want to carry what